c'était le 3 juin à moscou le politicien
dimitri goudkov sortait de prison après
48 heures de détention préventive les
autorités l'ont déposée devant ce mac
donald's ou sa femme le rejoint sous le
choc on lui a fait comprendre qu'il
avait quelques jours pas plus pour faire
ses bagages et qui tuent tous notre
famille nous l'avons joint sur skype à
kiev en ukraine où il s'est installé
temporairement pour réfléchir à son
avenir s'il rentre à moscou
il sera traduit en justice pour une
affaire de loyers non payés
un procès crée de toutes pièces d'utile
pour le tenir loin du bulletin lancé
députés étaient en effet un des favoris
dans son comté du nord de moscou en vue
des législatives de septembre
mais comme tant d'autres l'intimidation
a eu raison de ses ambitions politiques
quelques jours plus tôt un autre
opposant bien en vue a été arrêté sortie
même de force d'un avion qui s'apprêtait
à décoller de saint pétersbourg pour la
pologne
andré et piva rove ancien directeur du
parti open rachat est détenu depuis
il est accusé d'avoir publié en 2020 du
matériel au nom d'une organisation
indésirables pour le kremlin lui aussi
songé à se présenter aux élections et
soutenir des candidats d'opposition
des accusations faites sur mesure pour
effacer du terrain toute forme
d'opposition concède l'analyste année
kolesnikov et qui s'est dit il jusqu'où
ça ira
une étude menée par l'organisme russe de
surveillance électorale golos estime
déjà qu'au moins 8 millions d'heureux
sont privées du droit de solliciter un
mandat et ce en raison de lois
électorales ultra strict qui écarte de
facto les individus qui ont une double
nationalité
ceux qui font face à des accusations non
prouvées ou plus récemment les nier
personnes qui étaient associés de près
ou de loin aux mouvements d'alexis
navalni c'est de la répression de masse
comme on en a jamais vu même en russie
les violettes agrippina elle nous a
parlé depuis mourmansk où elle dirigeait
le bureau régional d'alexis navales
menées avant que l'organisme ne soit
étiqueté groupe extrémiste mis knock
elle a décidé de faire campagne à titre
d'indépendante pour battre le candidat
de la dîmière poutine au niveau
municipal
sauf qu elle en paie le prix voici les
fenêtres de son bureau tels que les a
trouvés il ya quelques semaines les
menaces par la poste et même les
arrestations suivies ces dépliants
anonymes distribués dans tout le
voisinage préviennent qu'elles aient
team pédophiles et publie même son
adresse personnelle
ils essaient de me chasser mais je
continue de me battre dit violetta même
si elle s'attend à ce que sa candidature
soit racheté 10 il vote en septembre
dimitri goudkov a décidé lui de s'enfuir
c'est avant tout pour protéger les siens
mais c'est un constat désolant en 2021
dit il
[Musique]
il n'ya plus l'espace légal pour
s'opposer au kremlin mais il ne se
considère pas en exil pour autant plutôt
un ambassadeur d'une autre russie plus
efficace et plus en sécurité que dans
son propre pays
et c'est dans ce contexte que les rues
seront appelés aux urnes après les
vacances d'été de ce support la chance
sans aucun suspense les jeux sont faits